this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by patreon
patreon is the reason that i'm able to
hire editors pay my hosts and create
extra content surrounding these shows if
you want to support us on patreon you
will get completely ad free versions of
the podcasts unedited podcasts extra
content q and a's and a whole bunch more
so if you would like to support the
return of red lips orange car go to
patreon.com charolanazard which i should
note if you're new here this is
technically the third season of this
podcast that is all about the weird
place where dating meets the internet it
is a comedy show and it is probably not
safe for work enjoy hello everyone
welcome to a new season of red lipstick
i'm alana these are my two permanent
co-hosts fiona
and charlotte
patrick is here as like a diversity
trial yeah we did it has been chosen
like i just prefer to
have people on shows for like their
their work um but we're giving you an
opportunity
well i just feel like a lot of it's been
because you're a white man and sure sure
and also because i don't podcast without
patrick right
this was a big compromise
i said i needed him i needed patrick to
be there he actually he actually wanted
to host the show which i was really
impressed by well i said i should be i
said i wanted to i said you must move
over you're like
oh right
now hang on he's already done it yeah
all right this is a show where we talk
about dating and the internet um that's
pretty much the thing and i have uh two
quick questions
um
what does this mean
this was found on craigslist uh it's
from northeast philadelphia milkman
retired milkman here looking to get back
to work anyone have any leads fiona you
want to take this no i'm sorry you
pointed directly at patrick did he have
something to do i was doing it yeah
oh okay i would love to take a crack at
it because i yeah i wanted i know i had
expertise with milkmen i mean i i've
i've known milkman
in the professional sense where they
deliver well this guy says he's a
professional what is this
i'm gonna guess this is either someone
who
milks a lot of
hog penis yeah
or someone who drinks a lot of breast
milk that's my guess and they've been in
a game for a while maybe they said so
you think it's either a
head
no it's not it could be a hand thing it
could be a hand thing it's not sex
though because that's what i think when
i think milking you don't milk a cow
with your mouth you milk a cow with your
hands right good point
i mean unless you're really good at it
now here's the here's the wild thing
guys because i'm such a lesbian i didn't
even put two and two together you didn't
think i was like i thought it was just a
milkman no honey no no no i was like
right now oh i like craigslist you're
telling me you're telling me
oh right because you can milk a man
where on coastline is this northeast
philadelphia isn't that where you're
from thank you where on the craigslist
website
uh it's just on uh miss connections okay
yeah that's what i would do because you
can get all kinds of things on
craigslist
this
[Applause]
uh well i can see that's off the 95 yeah
uh and i the fact that i said the 95
means i've been in
southern california for too long
because we just say we don't say the
before highways no one does that's just
that's just here so that's just 95. i
mean northeast philly that's where i'm
like from from i mean i recognize the
academy road yeah is it near four
seasons it's this is probably not far
from four seasons total landscaping
famed site of the is that in
philadelphia yes the four seasons total
landscaping is four minutes from where
it was almost like raised
incredible so that was huge you were
basically born there yeah it was right
near the sex shop i used to go to until
we moved out to six right
because you were
what's really interesting to me is that
they're retired yeah
and they want to get back to work
correct i think a milkman is
someone that specializes in hand jobs
and i'm not just talking about they like
doing hand jobs i mean
they're the [ __ ] person yeah you go
to them for that like they could be in
the yellow pages if we lived in a more
open-minded time sure oh okay so what is
so if someone wants like my would
someone be like hey i'm trying to find
like if someone wants a milkman yeah
yeah someone's trying to get jam jobs
they just go to this position they go
find a milkman yeah and it gets probably
like the word my guess is this
particular milkman just got out of a
long-term relationship retirement or
prison sentence or
that's not bad okay so we're voting
hand job specialists and do you think
that they're allowed to masturbate
during or do they have to wait until
afterwards not if you're a pro no no
that that
personal and professional lives have to
keep that's separate right yeah i think
you gotta talk out at the end of the day
keep the memory of it and then take it
elsewhere yeah
okay okay so that would be
unprofessional i have a second what does
this mean
um plumber skilled seeking work in
garden grove there's gardens very i
don't know very skilled 23 year old male
plumber for higher currently unplugging
pipes and garden growth i love what i do
and i'm great at it expert service for
discerning clients work done fully and
to completion every time guaranteed and
mess clean up after job come to my
office on harbor and find out about our
rates open to other jobs as well okay um
my whole dad's side of the family were
plumbers so i think this is just a
hard-working union man this is a real
plumber this is just a plumber he does
good work obviously says expert service
discerning clients you know this is the
la area garden grove so you might be
getting celebrities yeah he just wants
you to know hey i'm not gonna rat you
out
right i'm not gonna
talk about your stinky shoulders so this
is actually a plumber so and he cleans
up afterwards which is very professional
so yeah this is just a standard
obviously this is a union
okay
what do you think
well
yeah i mean it just seems like he's
great at unclogging pipes and garden
grove
and that he loves what he does
i mean okay but like okay if this was
sex yeah what would unclogging i know
but just like hypothetically speaking
i'm plugging i'm clogging pipes what
could that mean is that
is he just
removing
feces
what's unclogging like what is what's
clogged
that's a great question if you say
you're unplugging pipes are you
giving or taking yeah what
what's happening i guess i'm clogging
pipes is the ultimate give and take
just the fact that it says work done
fully into completion every time and
this is sex related which is it by the
end of it he's unclogged
yeah but it's i don't think that it's
about him being unclogged oh no but like
the person the client is unclogged and
this is cleaned up after job so
where's the mess going if i were
to think that this was sexual yes which
it is
absolutely not that if any if the chris
elliott movie cabin boy with andy
richter
it's that the term unclogging your pipes
is
for someone uh with a penis to come
because that's a pipe okay you're an
unclogged but i don't think it is
i think it's a it's a bad
term right but i've heard the term used
that way and she's like two hand job
people
you got you they call me
with like yeah full penetration and uh
holding in the mess until right until
they left i have a quick is a throat a
pipe
i think many why would the yeah why
would the throat be quite long
yeah maybe yeah
yeah
and the only thing that's going to clean
it up is a good cough a deep road yeah
i'm glad we finally got the two together
we are legitimately the opposite i have
no concept of anything i know that's why
i'm here
thank god you're here i know i'm so glad
we have a diversity will you also go to
this show and having you wanted is
actually to educate you one yeah
man teach me what's happening
okay so
plumber skilled seeking work in gardener
i love that this is written
professionally and i like to think that
they would show up in their plumbing
attire oh no you have to go to them
because it's come to my office yeah well
to find out about rates yeah that is an
interesting thing for appointments open
to other jobs as well that means it is
specific what
what other drops
well if we're staying within the realm
of plumbing
installation
probably yeah
yeah that counts too yeah some sneaking
of drains yeah but this is probably
something
surprising definitely snake drains yeah
i think you're right yeah i just
immediately i hear i'm clogging i'm like
oh this man's constipated what if we
think about it as
a metaphorical unclogging i'm talking of
tension i'm talking about society
i do think this one's [ __ ] though oh
okay yeah i mean that was that could
also be fun it could be totally that but
it could not be
you never know maybe you don't know it
makes you think why was i even asked
here
what is this show this is very helpful
no you don't buy cats
that's right all right okay it is time
to talk about expressvpn sending data
over an unencrypted internet connection
is like sending a postcard your message
is wide open for the mailman and any
other nosy people to see expressvpn
which is a virtual private network
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the internet in other words
it puts an envelope around your postcard
so that no one can sneak a peek at your
private correspondence expressvpn
encrypts your internet connection using
the highest standards of encryption
currently available expressvpn also
protects you from your own isp us isps
can legally sell your data to ad
companies expressvpn puts a stop to that
by rerouting and encrypting all your
data it also gives you unrestricted
access to all parts of the internet
think of a youtube video you weren't
able to watch a website you couldn't
visit a sports match you were unable to
stream that is how i started using
expressvpn is so that i could watch
premier league football expressvpn
allows you to reroute your connection to
a server in a country of your choice
making gr restrictions a thing of the
past they are consistently faster than
any other vpn provider have 24 7
customer support the app is extremely
easy to use and it is physically
impossible for any of expressvpn's vpn
servers to store logs of any customers
so find out how you can get three months
of expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com
alana or click the link in the
description box below i have uh paul's
craigslist miss connections from three
cities
from where each of you are from yeah
except that yours were all in french so
i did austin texas i'm really sorry
about that you could have done new york
i'm not from that place i was born
is that not the same yeah but
he was spirited away it doesn't matter
it doesn't remember like moses doesn't
matter okay so we've got newport beach
philadelphia austin texas sorry fiona um
i know nothing about texas by the way
that's the craziest part i feel like
they have i don't know i mean i lived
there for two years they got a little
bit of language that kind of indicates
where they're from i think okay i doubt
it the first one hi you were getting a
sammy and i was standing by you waiting
online
it was that easy you asked how was my
morning and i said better now you kind
of chuckled perplexed but then smiled
you asked about my day and i told you i
was going hiking you said that today was
a lucky day is this the second city nope
i think my lucky day was getting to talk
with you
you look about late 20s early 30 and end
in gear tree trim
maybe or some other outdoor work i was
dressed in jeans and a black sweatshirt
you start dang early maybe you're off at
three or four if so i could wait to
leave for that hike hmm
there's beautiful parks and stuff you're
not hiking there you could kind of you
got to get outside the city though i
feel like this sounds like is my hat
getting keyed out oh yeah let me turn
that off
sorry i just i just saw
um
okay so many clicks we're not living in
the future
i do not i mean hiking kind of i feel
like leads are what because newport
beach is california
it's texas
sammy
well it's a city of transplants is it
not it's true i mean like yeah and get
like a sandy sounds so east coast that i
could never
would you like me to read you all of
them before you put your guesses out
yeah
with this one i think that the person
who wrote this got the wrong read right
so they're both waiting to get their
sammies you asked how was my morning and
i said better now you kind of chuckled
perplexed but then smiled that's the
person you made uncomfortable my friends
yeah
how does that feel it sounds very texas
and then it went you asked about my day
and i told you i was going hiking you
said lucky day which i could see myself
doing like cool lucky day and then uh i
think my lucky day was getting to talk
with you yeah i think that this person
did not like this interaction at all no
it didn't go great okay number two
you're getting a sami everything's
different
it's true
um you're in a black tea and hat i keep
seeing you around and yesterday i
finally said something to you after a
show because you had been nice
tell me what show and maybe we have some
fun before this is all over so this is
definitely not newport beach because
there are no shows there okay there's
like conservative fundraisers
that's about us
not newport that's a show so show up
because like in texas maybe they have a
lot of like there's shops
yeah i mean this could be
philadelphia because
okay so
austin has shows philly
philadelphia like doesn't scream show to
me but i mean i think i may have
unlocked something okay with the hike
i think that the guy who posted it is a
weirdo yeah i agree right and yeah maybe
like walking out there a while ago but
maybe just walking to center city is a
hike for him yeah maybe that's a good
point oh maybe that's a term that's like
a way of saying they want to take a hike
yeah yeah yeah that's probably maybe not
a couple miles i will say i'm not
convinced that this isn't newport beach
because tree trimming
yeah what a ton of tree trimming yeah
wait what is what does that mean
california has a lot of tree trimming it
says you look about late 20s early 30s
and in gear tree trim maybe
here in gear it's newport because in
gear he's like hiking gear yeah yeah i'd
understand that hike it people no the
other person was in gear no this one no
it's this one it says there's no early
30s the poster is going on the hike the
person no the poster is wearing jeans in
a black sweatshirt yeah oh it's really
confusing why does it say you look about
late 20s early 30s and in gear because
this person does this person they were
writing it too was wearing because
they're barely illiterate yeah that's
what i'm saying
well who's going on a hike the person
he's talking it doesn't matter why are
they not out here okay fine [ __ ] me i
guess no no no no you're actually right
you also have one day and i told you i
was going home what kind of but you're
wearing hiking gear no but they don't
need this batman
let me let me read it again okay you
asked about my day and i told you i was
going hiking you said that was a lucky
day i think my lucky day was getting to
talk with you
you look about late 20s early 30s and in
gear tree trim maybe or some other
outdoor work so the poster is currently
wearing jeans in a black sweatshirt but
is going hiking later yeah and there
could wait for this person who's a tree
trimmer or possibly who starts dang
early maybe three or four
how do they know that
you this is a stupid situation really
early this is a stalker situation out of
all the things you were able to find
this location
i'm very much the last thing yeah
i'm worried about the woman is she alive
where are you shooting it's in yeah i'm
not sure
yeah is that okay to say patrick
okay so we're still we're still not
entirely sure we're gonna move on to the
third one yeah okay uh you would just
talk to nearby with your friends i was
leaving we locked eyes and smiled at
each other i let you know you looked
bomb you returned the compliment i
should have asked you a number but i was
in a hurry
i actually got no clues here that's
philadelphia in a hurry
what about bombs
you're in a hurry philadelphia i don't
know in new york it's like city life
you're in here oh philly it's not like
new york people people don't have
anywhere to be in philadelphia okay do
you still say bomb in philadelphia
i think we're we have to stop the ball
that's totally the bone patrick but no i
think we should consider who's posting
on craigslist in this year well weirdos
all weirdos so okay who's leading slang
and lingo
not weirdos they're probably hanging on
to stuff they could probably say things
are the bomb.com even where they say
that though yeah that's the question
you look i don't know what's the least
full place philly austin oh yeah no it's
mine it's for sure it's definitely yeah
actually i've never been to newport
beach so i can't
really it's extremely wealthy okay so i
i doubt they would say bomb yeah you
think so i don't think okay so we have
all three now yep i think the first one
is newport
i'm gonna agree with that i think this
is newport do you feel it in your blood
um this is probably us or texas or
something i guess a show is something
i don't know if it's ours
yeah charlotte
you think austin
so it's either this one or you're the
bomb yep
you're in a black what's the last one
she desperately wants this to be philly
because it's shows and that makes philly
look cool no phone right no we have a
big bell we don't need
shows enough okay this is a good clue
this is a good clue this person said you
looked bomb and then someone returned
the compliment like it was nice good
point good point but they could have
been scared
no because if i'm scared i'm
i would probably not have a compliment
in mind to tell that person i don't
think they had it in mind i think
they're like uh yeah you too please but
is that returning a compliment saying
you too i think to a craigslist poster
possibly
because this could be southern
hospitality right i should have asked
for your number but i was in a hurry
it's austin part of the south it feels
like an embassy from the north no
that may as well be yeah can i see the
previous one yeah so previous one one up
is you're in a black tea and hat i keep
seeing you around yesterday i finally
said something to you after show because
you had been nice tell me what show and
maybe we have some fun before this this
is philly that's philly yeah tell me
what show and maybe we have some fun now
this is really a cool
my gosh
um all right so that makes this one
austin austin yeah
this one's so non-descriptive this one
could also be any of them okay and that
would be like okay where do people lock
eyes i was particular about choosing
them like i did choose ones that i felt
had hints so uh i'm gonna tell you okay
you got you know
i do
you got
all of them wrong
yes really
no foolish 100 percent incredible every
single one of them okay yeah um you can
re-guess or i can just tell you uh no i
want to re-guess i want to try it
because
you've ruled some of that out okay just
kind of sit back this is nice
[Music]
okay we're going to we're just going to
what a show over here
yes one more okay this is sammy
i i'm going to go to this is
philadelphia i i buy that because the
sandy the sammy was like
so i'm going to say that's philly
i think show was awesome i'm gonna go
hike around love park
i think i'm going back to like what we
had five seconds before we decided to
change it completely
and then this is philadelphia no this is
new for it you are
correct all of them all correct we were
like this was it this was our yeah
completely
um that i figured would clue you off and
it did immediately and then you changed
your mind well i don't know what was
that there are there are hikes near
philly there's like parks and parkland
and also creepy people apparently nice
work for the wheel fan yeah yeah i had a
place pictured in my head that this
may have very well taken place at just i
picked the first sandwich place i
thought of
it it did actually it did actually name
it but i i edited out the name of the
shop whatever the sandwich shop was
because i figured it would be too much
for him oh do you remember it i do not
probably sandra's
whatever it was short it was like w
something
i don't know
oh my god
it's a gas station and people from
philadelphia [ __ ] love it new jersey
as well new jersey yeah it's the east
coast it's like weird say wawa and their
head [ __ ] extension
it's basically a 7-eleven well i'm not
waiting you're not you'll get this
it's not good you don't have anything
you don't talk
it is a gas station with mediocre food
but it used to be really good sandwiches
and like small shops but then they
expanded got worse bread and just made
all of the mega gas stations no it's why
i went like when you went
nice walking around
yeah
um
um the hint for this one is that this
was
actually taking place during south by
southwest so
that's why i i hoped that like maybe you
get i keep seeing you around because i
don't know what that is an event oh
i get it now yeah well they keep seeing
you around could have also been
philadelphia because of how kind of
because there are three people there
yeah they are just a good couple just a
handful of people so a good point but i
guess they're trying to uh
the the person in the black tea and hat
is a photographer oh okay okay didn't
have that detail and then this one yeah
i hoped that um bomb and hari would work
because in my head i assumed that was
late enough to be hurried hurry okay
well i did i did did i not make that
connection i was like hurry it needs to
be a city of some sort yeah but they're
all cities and you said it was philly
so i guess you still run into something
i don't know
yeah
um well it's supe that orange county is
super conservative
and it's very um
suburban but
uh culturally i would say it's very
different i have heard that is that
where the area is
no that's long beach that's still okay
but it's close it's like the next city
down so you almost did good is what i'll
say okay yeah almost
we did okay we now have some tinder bios
that we're gonna rate good ready i've
been off the market too long baby
come on and is this straight
tinder uh
you know i didn't check
um i did not you know what i come across
a lot of straight tinder because it's
just uh women who want it yeah literally
as i see a unicorn it's it's it's real
it's couples and people that want to and
i see the unicorn emoji and i want to
chew glass oh i love seeing this so the
unicorn is a woman like threesome with a
couple kind of yeah it's like a gay like
a gay person for them to experiment with
yeah it's like
our relationship isn't working because
we don't like each other and our
relationship is founded on convenience
let's get a queer yeah and it's always
and it's always lesbians and the amount
of times i've been a unicorn is probably
very traumatizing and i talk about it
with my therapist wow
like did you know that you are no
because it's usually straight women who
are like
hey like they kind of they actually
don't really tell you they're straight
until like you get too deep into it and
then they're like
oh i'm straight but i like you and i'm
like well i'm a whole woman
so you're not that straight and she's
like
[Music]
so uh are you you're sleeping with just
the woman or with both of you no i am
not sleeping with well that's that's
more like a threesome
yeah but they do want to include you in
that
and
eventually a lot of lesbians wanting to
do no no
that's why it's called the unicorn it's
because it's so rare
and so they're like
oh only so yeah and then so to the point
that now like women on dating apps um
have to write won't be your unicorn
most of my
tinder that i come across is
um
there's a lot of couples like every time
i get on the app so even if you're on
like the lesbian section of the app well
here's what happens
that's a picture of the woman for the
first two at least okay and maybe it's
just her name yeah yeah or you never see
him and it's only in the description
yeah whoa and it's usually the last
image yeah it's like a screenshot yeah i
mean a kayla always sends this is super
common oh yeah it's like constantly and
uh wow
and then yeah is that not violating like
in terms of service at all no i mean
it's just it's pretty fast and loose
i mean like there are fellas that get
through because they just i guess mark
themselves they just say yes
maybe i can change it it's like we went
today
we went to this gay beach day and it was
just this dude walking through this
throng of like the most the most
concentrated area of gay women you could
possibly it's literally a meet up for
lesbians yes and this guy kept being
like what's up i was like yeah wait and
i had a shaved head yeah i was like the
most most butch i've ever been in my
life and this guy came up to me i was
like please what if anything i am
wearing right now made me made you think
i wouldn't you want to be the target
there is no way there was a tinder bio i
ran i ran across when i lived in chicago
many years ago that i would see all the
time told you yeah i was a couple and
they were looking for a so it was a man
and a woman they were looking for
another man and you what would happen is
you would go to their this is all nearby
that's unique you'd go to their house
and
you uh the guy would suck your dick and
then you would [ __ ] his wife
but this was all in the bio yeah
and this is but here's the twist
when you're [ __ ] his wife he's gonna
try to little scamp that he is like a
little raccoon he's gonna try to get in
there and suck your [ __ ] dick and you
gotta keep him away you gotta swat him
away while you [ __ ] his wife you're like
no no
you've already sucked my dick get out of
here scram
and it would come up their bio would
come i don't know if they were making
new bios but i would see
i'd see them again
the next time i opened it i think they
had like 30 bucks does it say the ones
what in that yeah
i made i may be adding some stuff you're
a storyteller i'm a snatcher
i mean like they didn't call them a scam
[ __ ]
[Music]
right now get rid of them
at least they laid it out i know i
appreciate it and like if that's your
kink
you know good for you for being so open
and knowing exactly what you want for it
and getting out there and laying it all
out there wow but that's what they're
interested in
oh my god i forgot about that one
that's incredible yeah
that's the best tinder bio i've ever
seen
it's also very easy for the woman she
doesn't really
[Music]
my favorite part is
[Laughter]
[Music]
making profiles every day
baby
the one oh my god all right i have i
think five tinder profiles that we're
gonna write in order okay the first one
looking for my lovely ever after must be
blonde or brunette be fit and toned go
to the gym four times weekly over four
times
be no more than five eleven and no less
than five four in height be available at
all times give good hit be able to cook
and clean devote as much time as
possible to me as possible have a steady
income of over seventy thousand dollars
per year have owned apartment that i can
crash at occasionally if you fit these
criteria swipe right i will not settle
for anything less also not interested in
bbws and single moms
um
okay
there's a lot of pack here i swear left
on single moms just because i'm ready
for that kind of connection absolutely
sure i mean
it's a you know the nature of the site
is that yeah so the preferences are
immediately okay so we can start with
this one at zero you know just well this
is a zero for sure but it's what's fun
is maybe we can guess what kind of guy
wrote this is how are you big beautiful
woman or big a big black man i actually
i have two i think people have big black
women
it's if it's big beautiful women then
he's fine so it's right
no he's not interesting
big women
i mean he didn't even he didn't even
like write interested right now
so how do you have this much time for
someone and cook and clean out and have
a seventy thousand dollars
so he wants yeah he wants a instead he
wants more time another person to have
us over seventy thousand dollars okay i
think i know what's happening i think
this is someone who spent a lot of time
in very dark strange sections of youtube
and reddit and i have gotten a lot of
info from some very misinformed people
about how to have
about
rules in a household yeah you could be
right and uh you know that kind of thing
and but also it's like she's gonna not
like you if you don't make her if she's
not this much she's gonna lead you gonna
be alpha some [ __ ] like that oh
i'm guessing that's what's going on what
you're saying is that amanda respects
himself
yeah that's important
it's a little weird because he asks her
to have her own apartment that he can
crash at occasionally this guy has to
also be able to cook and clean what his
apartment or her own apartment good
question wherever he is i guess that's
yeah well it says devote as much of your
time to me as possible yeah let me let
me put this out there i am bernat
i could be more do you fit this
i already go to the gym oh you actually
yeah go more i'm five eight five eight
yeah
available at all times
who needs the stream
yeah
amazing yeah cooking clean
all the time
yeah you do
as much as my time to be him as possible
thank you i have an apartment that you
can crush it occasionally i think i'm
making the money i have an apartment
yeah but yeah so you're right no it
still counts have owned apartment i got
i think what's up i have a master
bedroom so i have a bathroom off of it
yeah that's basically a studio
single mall
no you're not even a perfect there it is
i don't think so
this is local we've done it so this is
not local now are they twenty one yeah
twenty one or thirty one
i think it's thirty
are we supposed to rate these well yeah
but we're going to rate them like
okay okay okay so number two here
is uh pretty different um
you will be the luckiest girl on the
planet sure catch me if you can let's
have pizza and sushi or let me cook
six to 1.88 meters no what is that a
woman that is european there you are oh
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you six foot
two with that a woman that is a woman is
like a diamond the more hands that will
touch her the less she will shine
oh
traveling the world let's travel
together oh look you know what okay it's
so gross this is this just looks like
the i don't know if you guys watched the
tinder swim blurry this just looks like
a vibe
i started it but i don't like a
documentary that's too slick
yeah it's probably basically yeah
sometimes it's like this is just too
much you know yeah
it's it's almost fine weird not
something that i would swipe right now
almost
it's [ __ ] stupid and i don't like it
but it's weird it's acceptable behavior
i would say maybe i'm just picky it's
the type of thing you would see
i'm not picking them it's the type of
thing the first chunk of the bio is like
this is too this is like right it's like
oh come on and then it goes oh what the
[ __ ] and then it's like oh
yeah
why do you capitalize p and planet and
world
and then let's travel and together yeah
this is a secret code yeah
yeah
insane clown insane pound classy
what does it mean
you viewer must figure out the cipher
so let us know
i have not ever used dating apps how
frequent do people say this type of [ __ ]
the the luckiest thing on the planet
well the fellas are different i would
say yeah i get i'm not this is if this
is straight tinder i don't i don't i
assume this is straight yeah this is a
man so like there's no there's no
lesbians going you'll be the luckiest
jesus christ
i was gonna say there's emoji usage
there is emoji usage but usually it's
just bad jokes does mine have emojis
yeah
that's what i would do it's like bad
jokes the first part that like if we
have a match will be the luckiest i mean
i've never seen anything like that
granted i'm looking at
straight women right but yeah i would
say the second they'll like catch me if
you can let's have i see you'd see that
[ __ ] that's pretty that like goofy let's
have pizza pizza and sushi let me cook
i've said that yeah and the height i i
hear is common
height is super common yeah
because well no no so what i would see
is
height requirements on a lot of people a
lot of women requested yeah like height
requirements
on their body what are the height
requirements usually probably over like
but it's a lot of like if you are under
five i'm gonna say ten five ten i think
five if you're under five ten like great
keep on walking yeah it's like if you're
doing as well you're five stars
five eight
but i'm teeth i'm fatigued
it's a lot of like
if you're under this height don't bother
messaging type wow i dated somebody who
was shorter than me i didn't run with it
it was fine well
yeah they're all right with it
so that that's like one thing like i've
usually been the taller person in my
like relationships and i like being with
someone who was taller than me i didn't
see but again it's it's lesbian
relationships i didn't really like i
mean it's not like i'm like oh no she's
tall and i can't i want that
you want someone who's i want someone
taller than me
yeah yeah i i guess
two
well do you want six two one point
do they will they have pizza and sushi
wait be careful catch em if you can well
there's been a lot of haters on the
planet yeah
what do you think the purpose of
including this in a dating app bio is
they probably think it's profound like
he probably thinks that like it's
endearing to a woman now yeah this is
like say he finds a girl that fits this
criteria the criteria being like pizza
liking pizza and sushi okay easy but
like he probably thinks that like if
someone has been like say she's only
been with like one person maybe this is
like so validating that you'll swipe
right on this [ __ ] up yes yeah
well it's also like a lot of women he's
trying to project that he's not
promiscuous himself maybe
i also think there's a lot of like pick
me women who would read that and be like
that's me that's so true yeah i've only
had sex with 15 guys like there is a lot
that i've mentioned which is cool
yeah which is you should have sex with
these 15 guys and that's everyone
get to work i got a lot
you gotta catch up you gotta catch up
yeah it's like john wick two are you
here for the pope
so between these two who's who's first
and who's second to start on the ranking
what's
in his first batch top yeah
i think this one's more on the surface
sinister i think the other one so this
is wasp yeah i think the other one has
some demons that you're not going to
yeah
right away this is emotional
manipulation and um
right off the bat like crazy
i mean both of them are i'm right you're
right
like if you were to see them
which one you'd go on a date with i just
worry that like the first one on its
face it's like well no you don't get
anything you're asking right because
you're a fool yeah the second one i
could see women falling prey to that so
that's why i'm gonna say that one's
worse yeah that is worse also six two
like if you're in like if there's like a
guy in like mediocre shape yeah that's
six two
that will be enough that you're right
yeah
yeah number three
ceo of tick tock turn
i know this is bothering you i know this
is bothering you what the intense
[Music]
for some reason
the word doc did i don't know why it did
that patrick knows the things
because oh there you go hang on how's
that
really yeah is that good yeah does it
seem right yeah
okay ceo of tick tock just an old person
at heart trying to find his way in a sea
of [ __ ] boys once you get to know me
you'll realize that i'm pretty goofy
i'm pretty open and upfront and believe
in being honest and straightforward i
love driving and going on road trips
okay
all right they're anthem yeah i wish we
could suck things probably imagine
dragons
smokers
coldplay yeah yeah yeah maroon 5 maybe
newberry
for these fuckboys what is this
that's why i kept it in was that i found
that to be an odd choice for someone
saying trying to find his way in to see
a [ __ ] yes get a different job then
yeah right you shouldn't be the ceo
yeah do you think this is
is that the same
is that i did it would be somebody in
china
you would think
he's worth 49 and a half billion
[Laughter]
yeah i mean honestly this is probably
the best one okay this one's all right
listen i i don't love i'm pretty goofy i
mean that's just
stormy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's just
kind of like this is just somebody yeah
you're right it's like the ceo of tick
tock but that strikes me as being very
offline this is someone we would have
met at the 100 thieves party we went to
yesterday yes we would have 100
this dude this is this this dude was
there you're absolutely right probably
pretty goofy at that yeah yeah but like
we couldn't see it because we were good
yeah but if he if we'd spoken him we
would have found out that he's gonna
okay the next one
i think women are foolish to pretend
they are equal too can patrick read this
to get the photo yeah yeah go ahead well
okay
it does take a time oh yeah okay so we
might wanna i think alana i think you
take thank you yeah yeah i think women
are foolish to pretend they are equal to
men they are far superior and always
happy whatever you give a woman she will
make it greater if you give her sperm
she will give you a baby yes if you give
her a house she will give you a home if
you give her a smile she will give you
her heart she multiplies and enlarges
what is given to her so if you give her
any crap be ready to receive a ton of
[ __ ] now name every single emoji this is
wave emoji
man dancing emoji woman dancing emoji
man dancing emoji threesome threesome in
the ocean
yeah literally
in the scene in the wave pool it's not a
cruise ship
this [ __ ] is worse than just being like
literally i would prefer i'm here for
sex
yes yes yeah i am the sea of [ __ ]
also like yeah also like the first line
is like you had me at the first half not
gonna lie type meme like yeah i was like
oh no he's gonna he's
which i think a lot of people don't
realize is super off-putting that's the
biggest it's extremely well also like
maybe
the answer this maybe this guy hasn't
met all women because if you give me
sperm i'm not gonna be able to do much i
don't yeah exactly
she will give you a baby i'm not i can't
do it
[Music]
this is bad she multiplies and enlarges
what is given to her it's not that one
does sound good
five lyrics
yeah you're not wrong you give her any
crap
i also i don't know what these emojis
are the emoji it's like the dancing and
the dancing in the on the beach
yeah it might be right or
they're about to drown that woman
they're about to drown
why is it two minutes because it's two
guys profile
they wrote it together it's like yeah
yeah what do you think about this sperm
line yeah yeah oh yeah you're right
that's
sick bro that's so good never mind that
was totally changed
[Applause]
yep it's terrible okay um this is the
last one okay this is the linkedin yeah
there's two more i guess it's too much
you don't think he was wearing a fake
mustache i did i did i couldn't you were
drunk no i wasn't even that drunk i'm
trying to help you
no you're right you you've got you gave
me your mind
you gave me a line
and i cut it with my scissors it was
halloween
i could have been wearing a fake i think
it's because how perfectly like
something about it it's well groomed
it's very well groomed that i was like
that's fake i grew up here today it's a
good chat don't say her
it's like a ship or a clean air plane
yeah i wish you would break a champagne
bottle against it
okay
would you like to have a relationship
that 99 involves me catering to your
every whim supporting you financially
and giving you head you can also date
and or [ __ ] other people and i will
still remain faithful one way open
relationship yes i'm legit serious if
i'm into you obviously if anyone cares i
have three master's degrees engineering
sociology and history i'm a certified
massage therapist right and i produce
idiom wolf oh they hand me to them
until the end yeah yeah add me and then
add me on snapchat yeah right and it's
got the ig yeah so um it is time to talk
about the second annual video game
accessibility awards which just aired on
my youtube channel a couple of weeks ago
at youtube.com charlamazon this whole
show was sponsored by pizza hut pretty
obviously and was co-hosted by myself
alana pierce and steven spahn one of my
best friends in the whole world and i'm
talking to you about it today to try to
convince you to watch it a whole lot of
blood sweat and tears effectively went
into making this show possible and it is
a show that is funny we have a lot of
comedy skits features a lot of really
cool people like ryan reynolds and
jacksepticeye and dr lupo and the game
grumps and we'll also do a great job of
teaching you a whole bunch about video
game accessibility and why it's
important so with a very big thank you
to pizza hut you can catch the show on
youtube.com taralanazad you may already
be watching this podcast on youtube.com
charlatazard which makes it extra easy
go and check it out for the only
hour-long award show in existence that
is mostly full of jokes a lot of pizza
and a very important mission now back to
the podcast
about this one yeah whole thing's a lie
whole thing's a lot it's a person trying
to like get more instagram followers or
some [ __ ] oh
[Music]
my theory is that this is a recruiter
and the job is a relationship that
caters to the employee supporting them
financially and gives them a head i
forgot about that
we just crossed that one out you could
also date or [ __ ] other people i mean
yeah your job's not supposed to keep you
from [ __ ] what is up with these bot
people thinking they need to write all
of this down for the bio i mean either
i'm doing the dating apps for how long
are they supposed to be i i for the next
episode i was going to have people
submit their bios for us to rate but i
thought that i would do an introductory
episode first so we'll put up an email
in the description so people can send
them through and we can
delicately give some tips yeah yeah i um
maybe i'm just really bad at making bios
because i write very little do you are
you one of those people that's like
here's my insta if you actually want to
get at me find me there
cuz like well no i i put it in there and
k because sometimes i don't want them to
like i'd rather they reach out to me on
instagram because i'm never on the app
like if i'm not on the app for like a
week yeah and then i'm like oh you could
have reached out with that and part of
why i don't think i'd ever use a dating
app is that i would want them to have no
idea who i am so then there's no
interest so so that they can't
screenshot my [ __ ] and post it on well
that's what they've done
it has happened to me many times i've
actually been on a date with someone who
knew exactly who i was and lied
i've heard too yeah and and that's why
like you told me on the third date
actually the thing is what i've realized
is on tinder i can only be there for
three days and then i have to delete the
i have to delete the app why because i
either get on the third day it's either
a screenshot it is either someone saying
hey fiona's on there like
then now i can't trust any match i have
and then um
and it just like i just can't be there
for more than three days
however i have been trying hinge and
that's a lot better
okay so tinder for me is like i'm not
going to be on that that'll be my thing
it's like if people yeah just like take
you organizing a date and leak it or
like yeah literally so that's that's
scary to me so yeah only like i'm on
there for like three but yeah i feel
like if they knew who you were what this
this was on okay cupid i just remember
that okay cuban is totally valid oh two
people we've gotten married
today yesterday
the marketing right now for okay pretty
good
very nice it's normal to be on okay
cupid it sucks yeah
it wasn't it just wasn't working for me
i tried okay cupid i tried hinge and i
tried bumble all bad time was the only
place i was getting matches i don't know
for me i don't know if yeah and she's
already taken so what am i going to do
i don't know i i don't know if like
people on those abs don't get down with
trans women but for some reason tinder
has been way better tinder is definitely
a lot more open yeah tinder is a lot
more open but more people probably
there's more i think it's more people
because bubble it's like it's more
people and it's easier to make a profile
like on tinder you can make a profile oh
yeah okay you could just do a [ __ ]
personality yeah well same with hinge
like you have to like all right you have
to look through you have to literally
put in six pictures and end a video
something like it needs to be like yeah
yeah like they do they recommend they do
voice memos that's nice
we should actually look at the voice
levels on hinge because some of them are
at some point yeah i mean they could set
up a fake account for the purposes of
getting content um that's brand new well
don't like link up facebook or something
no no
i don't know hitch may be more involved
but you could probably just find them
out there just that is a way for me it's
like tick tock yeah i'll do it don't
just find them oh and it's anyway it's a
lot of them are like
so anyway i'm tucker um i don't know
what i'm really doing here but i do
actually a really good mega mind
impression yeah literally anyway so here
it goes
it's literally really that is really
cool actually yeah maybe it's the
lesbian side of hinge too but like a lot
of those voice prompts are our funniest
i got off after they added things oh
yeah
someone tinted their mirror i think
their cupid seems fine to me i think
it's fine it's just so old it's like
what it's like
i was using
[Applause]
yeah we keep reinventing she makes a
great point
it's pretty awesome anyway my tinder
okay cupid dates wait look look at okay
i just think it's strange to still be on
it it's all that's all i'm saying can i
say something about my tinder profile
that i forgot you may i am no i saw this
the other day and
so you can link your spotify right yeah
mine is broken and i think it's because
i listened to a lot of halsey's last
album that she produced with the guys
from nine inch nails which is super good
but tinder has my top track on spotify
as closer by the chainsmokers oh no
you're that person i don't know where it
pulls from because after that is laura's
mood ring which i barely listened to
that and they said closer by nine inch
nails
that would be great that's actually the
more close to what i was listening to
and then there's like mr brightside and
a marshmallow song because it's
featuring churches whoa this is
less like you know big i would say i
mean rainy wolf's blown up no one can
argue with that there's a group on here
i've never heard of
anyway it's just it's really bizarre and
i should disable my spotify but i'm now
at the point where i want to get matches
despite having yeah
everybody close your eyes i don't want
you to see this man again because it
will call off
the impression we're just going to
scroll past okay here we go can i open
you can open
my eyes were closed now
don't stop looking at that okay now is
the time to fight now is the time to
organize now is the time to stop the war
on women now is the time to end rape
culture now is the time to protect and
defend our people all color and peoples
of different faiths now is the time to
fight and bleed and revolt now is the
time to resist donald trump in his
cabinet of patriarchy with everything we
have italy now is the god damn time we
must join together we must fight we have
caught
to a permanent end this guy this guy 12
miles away
yeah what is this is this from the
administration
update their tinder sense
joe or even the black protest that
happened in 2010 yeah
[Laughter]
how many genders are there they went at
least three
[Applause]
thank you
yeah honestly they're probably the best
dancer
in office yeah he's not right
at least is there a type of woman who
sees this and likes it and says this is
the kind of [ __ ] okay
there's this thing that definitely
exists on twitter which is always white
feminists and there are white female
fans resistance
are oppressed full stop tweet thousand
reasons someone should do something
about this all the time stop harassing
women send tweet clap emojis tweet yeah
so i think this is what it works
yeah which is okay
keep harassing women
i'm pro-patrol we're all pro-patriarchs
yes right of course
so i think it's those girls who i always
assume are like it's weird because it's
like i don't disagree with what you're
saying but i'll shut up though well
they're they're not taking into
consideration anyone else other than a
white woman well i also don't think
they're even like yeah
what they're saying i think they just
say it to look like they're granted oh
yeah it was like it's like the black
it's like the black profile pictures or
like the black square
yeah
i was like yeah i was like damn that
damn y'all are helping you you did it
but they're always like 20 they're
really young yeah they're like sure
studied one feminism class and now
they're like yeah so it's this guy for
those girls like this feels like a weird
over correction that this you just found
out the best oh you think he's a massive
racist are you kidding me no no i don't
think he's a voice oh he just got out of
that success i think he just found out
about sex
wait a minute so much
did like 20 minutes of hard research
yeah he did it on his private browser
first he googled like feminist twitter
right that's right yeah found some and
then was like yeah these people are
right i'm pissed off yeah
i gotta [ __ ] also
i'm gonna write this like i want to make
sure i'm [ __ ] you didn't do this
yeah i could do both yeah yeah look i
respect the intentions
if they are yet i mean yeah speaking of
speaking of that black square because i
just remembered this i remember there's
a big tick topper her name's like
charlie demilia or something like
yeah she's like the biggest she's like
at the beginning she's talking about
she's the ceo and she must be
you know at this point
oh my
what are god doing what time are you
making yes oh god though um
no child charlie demilio had that her
profile picture as the black square
for years and i remember on tick tock
there we people yeah there were there
are people on tick tock are like black
people on tic tacs saying well she
better not change that because that's
racist as hell and she did like people
were like not allowing her to change it
she kept it was like after the black
person
but she kept it going until like like
it's still on her profile picture and
then the joke was like well if she
changes it now
oh yeah the joke is commitment
you committed too hard that reminds me
of when the fun house uh socials were
never changed from pride [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and the whole time i was like yeah if
you take it off now now it's homophobic
yeah
it was the funniest thing that story was
so that was really that was happening
yeah
i was literally i was watching avatar
and i saw it on facebook and i was like
filming i imagine oh yeah yeah yeah
oh i was
james cameron's as a cartoon
oh no we're talking yeah i think you're
talking about eminem
live action got it got it i was watching
that and i saw the pony thing and i was
like this is awful
i must post something i posted something
hey i didn't hate it but i didn't buy
the bracelets you should i didn't
monetarily support it
who got the
i love boobies for breast cancer i had
like a whole arm filled of them
i do love boobies and breast cancer
breast cancer i hate breast cancer i
hate breast cancer
boobies so let's protect them at all
costs by buying a wristband thank you
yeah um all right so we're gonna just
which does anyone have any takers for
which of these is the worst i don't even
remember the past two this one's the
worst this is probably the worst so we
have
man who'd give her and close our eyes
charlotte
uh man who wants to fight
yeah you open your eyes again we have uh
the one that like the guy who produces
edm the [ __ ] the guy
yeah
we have uh he's just trying to get off
superior it always happened yeah yeah
um ceo
this one's at the bottom yeah this is
the most okay this is the best one this
is the yeah okay
it's not good but it's the best it's the
best one what what is the biggest
mistake ceo of tick tock made
this the the finding is way in a sea of
[ __ ] boys definitely lying this is not
chang yeah
[Music]
yeah he's like old soul i'm in agreement
that this one's pretty homeless it just
comes across as pretentious it's just
sure yeah yeah that's that's that's fine
the bar is low driving is a weird hobby
that's fine well yeah but people like
driving i just love it
finding their way through a sea of [ __ ]
boys is like well yeah we all know yeah
we all know that yeah
you can also see from the photos which
you see before the bio whether or not
there's a [ __ ] boy
he's he's like making it's like pitying
himself he's like just for sure
i think he's embarrassed about being
yeah yeah he's being like i guess i
gotta be on this boxing ceo of tick tock
though that is that's so so slow and
it's also very
weird different to the rest of it but it
ain't anything right tick-tock correct
like there's no there's no space yeah
no it's back to the bottom yeah um he
wins then he's at the only one
yeah yeah so but we still have to pick
the loser the worst the loser
is this one's so good we don't like this
one i know i came back around i like
this i i like this i want to be more
right for him the only reason i think
this is
better than the other he's not a
performative he's honest he's
very foolish he has his he has his
boundaries he's an [ __ ] but he's
saying
he's patrick bateman but he's telling
you that he's patrick yes he will yeah
and
it's it's easily avoidable it's like a
you're right a massive sinkhole but
there's signs all around it's never
gonna work unless the one woman who
wants this in which case happy for us
the other guy thinks he's smart and he's
probably gonna preach that around to
other people the last one the one that i
think is the worst like he thinks he's
saying facts double king
yeah he's saying and he's 19. he's the
worst i hate it i absolutely hate him i
think he's a little farmer
i don't want to see the picture until i
suppose oh
look at that oh
let me read the caption i think that's
cute
now
so this is fiona's
least favorite it's the worst one
anybody else did i see him again though
okay 19.
i mean it's definitely like like i i
don't like i hate these like it's the
cringiest it's i think yeah i mean it's
pretty bad i i think this
now is the time to end rape but i think
my thing is just that i find it like
like it's just in my head it's a kid who
just like thinks they're doing the right
thing but i want to beat him up so bad
to other people i can ignore and move on
with my like this guy he might be into
that
he might let you
he might like he might be like
yeah literally it looks great this is uh
that's like that that's the past version
of uh this guy
you're right
this one's pretty bad to me this is the
women of foolish to pretend they equal
to men they'll fall superior and always
happen this one's pretty off-putting
it's just like it's so like the only way
i can get a woman attracted to me is by
debasing
yeah myself yeah like and saying like
you are goddess and it's
maybe if you have a hobby though that
would help do you have any interests
just like you're just just
confident just yeah yeah just like just
a little confidence goes a long way you
know just
i just don't i don't i wouldn't want to
be with someone who's constantly
respecting me no yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah literally literally i actually
like this one the least this is if we
have i always think that's the luckiest
girl on the planet
i hate that and i also hate catchments
catch me if you can pisses me off so
much with the handover yeah
i'm hard to get like shut the [ __ ] well
that's better than i'll catch you right
honestly there shouldn't be any noise
we've got fiona's least favorite patrick
yeah miley's favorite yeah who loses i
think uh
scroll down
ceo of tick tock no no that's nothing
women are foolish this might lose just
because you put the word sperm in a
dating biologist
which is insane behavior
that is completely deranged
that's bad and what was the last word
the farmer boy yeah last one oh this one
no uh
i i think i'm gonna go this is a lie i
still think this is he just is trying to
get people to follow him for his edm
yes this is an advertising profile
i mean i don't like
there's like three of them that i don't
like for the same reasons yeah but i
think um i'm gonna go with the one i
said just to mix it up this one i think
that i'm gonna go with this one just to
kind of make it sorry about that yeah
i think there's scarier ones
i just don't like that quote that that
guy put in between the sparkles
and like you know for like a i don't
know how old this person is but like a
young woman that's on like an app like
this that really just upsets me the idea
of like this is the only one that is
absolutely it just feels like let me
cook let's have pizza let's have sushi
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
what are you like this is really what i
find actively offensive the others i'm
like ugh
this one i'm like what the [ __ ] man this
this feels harmful yeah and like i said
it could work i think first for like
like very simple right but for a really
bad reason like a low self-esteem i
think someone could trip into this yeah
and that's really scary okay
like a woman who thinks that that is a
valid perspective for somebody else to
have about how many people yeah and
and like to have that
channel there's a lot a lot of youtube
channels about being a classical woman
classic
you know i am
and
i feel like that type
go for this van we're sorry about
talking about your space show sister i
feel like she would be auntie tinda
though
oh definitely she would be like there's
other she's anti like eating in front of
men does she she wouldn't be like yeah
she's like you should hold a napkin in
front of your face type [ __ ] like yours
ben shapiro's sister has a youtube
channel oh no yeah and it's all about
how to be a good woman
yeah and
she does movie reviews
we should watch one of those next steps
yeah yeah let's watch movie reviewers
enemy of the show and we have the show
classically uh number one feud um but
thank you guys so much for joining us
yes
i'm sorry i'm wearing my i love boobies
braces
uh thank you all for joining me for the
first episode of season three of red
lips orange cup patrick where can people
find you
twitch that tv slash what a show give
that plug first thank you that's what we
do and that was the best place
it's the only place i'm active i also am
on twitter at handsomemaster23
one of those private though i think just
two on twitter
i think the other ones the other ones
are private the private one might be 23.
i think it's you on the private one you
just swear
you follow my crap it's just it's just
weird plumbing it's just people i know
just kidding
just unclogged
unclogging
movement yeah respecting women writing
that exact quote handsomeness
on twitter yeah twitch.tv
don't follow 23. charlotte you won't get
in uh you can find me at mc underscore
lada that's l-o-t-t-a twitch.tv
what a show we have a podcast it's
called ship hits the fan
we're very excited about that yeah yeah
it's doing well we're very excited about
it too yeah someone just made us a
little custom tech deck cool 14 in
australia
charts that's amazing that's me yeah
it's fallen
my mom told her book club about it but
anyway that's it and also you can listen
to uh mom's home wherever you get music
so it makes me feel mom's
like no that's me you can find me
twitter uh fiona nova and then instagram
fiona underscore nova because someone
took it we should cancel them i'm trying
to get it and i'm also just trying my
best to live so yep it happens like it
comes at you fastly
uh this podcast goes up on the second
monday of every month i think is what i
try to schedule for third it's the third
monday of every month thank you for
joining us we will see you next month
bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you